foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview I'll first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines
tonight with Jasmine Cameron chaleshi
and Camilla Turner so very good to see
you both I'm very pleased to say that
they will both be with us uh from now
until midnight first of all let's take a
look at what's on some of the front
pages and the Daily Telegraph leads with
the war in Ukraine reporting Putin set
to declare occupied Land part of Russia
on the cost of living crisis The Daily
Mail says Freedom begins with tax cuts
trust signals profound a shift in policy
writes the Ft on possible tax cuts
and the eye also leads with that story
with their headline mortgage rates shock
as trust Cuts UK taxes
the new pm to cut stamp Duty in push for
Prosperity is the Times front page
the guardian says Biden rejected the new
PM's Embrace of reaganite tax policies
a Thoroughly Modern monarchy for King
Charles says the mirror
the express says the public backs this
move for a slimmed back monarchy
the Metro has the new king and queen
consort returning to Balmoral to
continue their morning in private
and the star has the so-called queue
jumping Saga involving this morning
television host Holly Willoughby and
Phil Schofield on its front page
and reminded by scanning the QR code
that you can see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
foreign
but let's bring in then Jasmine Cameron
chaleshi and Camilla Turner to go
through those papers and it's
interesting isn't it that uh
Liz truss our new prime minister who was
only in the job for two days before
National morning of course started after
the announcement of the Queen's death
but now uh the spotlight is back on her
and all the front pages pretty much
focusing on the days ahead you've picked
out uh Jasmine first of all that the
Financial Times front page their
headline is trust signals profound shift
in policy with defense of tax cuts and
it looks like we're going to get
announcement at the end of the week with
more details on that
yeah so it's quite a pivotal week for
trust as you mentioned she became PM she
announced her energy package and then
obviously we had the passing of the
queen and so her government was forced
to sort of you know change tact and
change tone and government business
couldn't continue as usual but now we've
passed this period of national warning
she's in a sense got to introduce
herself to the public got to introduce
herself to MPS and really cram in a lot
of policy over a quite a small period of
time and so this week we're expecting a
bit more detail on some of the um
support for businesses facing Rising
energy costs we're expecting an
announcement on the NHS on Thursday but
more crucially we are expecting sort of
mini Budget on Friday and this is where
we're really expecting to see some of
those promises that we saw
um trust talk about for our leadership
campaign the slashing of National
Insurance the slashing of the planned
corporation tax hike we're really
expecting to see some of those and be
introduced to the House of Commons and
it'll be quite interesting to see how
MPS react to some of her policies
now if we look to her cabinet for
example her cabinet is filled with
loyalists those who have backed her and
really support her her and ideology
particularly on things like tax cuts
whereas the back benches are filled with
you know Rishi sunak supporters
supporters of Boris Johnson so it'll be
it will be really interesting to see how
some of these economic policies really
go down with the MPS well yeah
absolutely and I'm just going to show
everybody the Times newspaper Camilla
because I know that you won't have had a
chance to look at this so I'm not going
to quiz you on the detail but it's the
headline is interesting they're saying
trust the cut stamp Duty in push for
Prosperity so if the times is right
that's another tax cut that could be on
the cards and as the financial times
does report here and as this trust told
our political editor as well she's very
keen to defend this criticism that her
tax cuts are unfair that they are
benefiting the wealthy the most she says
she's prepared to be unpopular on that
but she thinks it's in the interest of
growth
yes that's right in this story and the
times about the stamp Duty cut is just
another example of all these um quite
drastic measures Liz truss is looking to
introduce
um to try and do what what she sees as
as being the most crucial thing which is
to inject some growth into the economy
um and we can see in that Financial
Times article
um she's really launching quite a
staunch defense of her
um plan here saying that she's going to
be doing unpopular things like lifting
the cap on Bankers bonuses like
um reversing the National Insurance hike
which of course benefits working people
and disproportionately benefits those
who are higher earners so some of these
measures which aren't on the face of
them going to help the poorest in
society but what she argues well overall
benefit Society because they'll inject
that much needed growth into the economy
um and that will over time
um lead to the UK's Prosperity whether
that comes to fruition or not and
particularly in the time frame let's say
before the next general election which
is only two years time and remains to be
seen it is a bit of a gamble we're
having here from Liz trust with these
slightly longer term policies which may
not be popular immediately but could
well yield
um fruit in the longer term
um but just how long that will take I
think will be the the major taskbar well
yes and and as Jasmine was saying
interesting to see how her own MPS
respond to it as well as the markets and
the public and her argument then
um Jasmine is that everyone will benefit
ultimately if the pie is bigger but if
you look at the front page of the
Guardian they are leading on the fact
that
um the U.S President Joe Biden today
um tweeted his rejection of this this
kind of policy Downing Street very quick
to say it's ludicrous to say that that
was in response to the UK's plans
um but the timing's a little bit
unfortunate there for Liz Truss
it was quite unfortunate and bear in
mind that trust and Biden the duty I
think had their first bilateral meeting
and tomorrow so it was a very
interestingly timed tweet and he was
saying that he was sick and tired of
this idea that trickle-down economics
would would benefit
um you know all groups in society from
the lower income to the high income I
mean I don't think it's any surprise
that trust and Biden aren't necessarily
um economic bed fellows I don't think
that's a surprise to anyone but I do
think it's slightly embarrassing to
trust he was trying to introduce herself
to MPS introduce herself to world
leaders and really put forward her
staunch economic policies so I think
it's slightly awkward timing and just
touching on what Camilla was saying
about
um the fact that trust is you know very
happy to be unpopular
um I think it's a very interesting
stance to take because it's important to
step back and remember that trust was
only elected you know with the support
of a very you know small pool of
conservative members she didn't even
have the backing of the majority of MPS
who were in support of where she seen
that so you think that now would be the
time of sort of reaching out and not you
know not really wanting to alienate the
public for some of these policies that
can be seen as disproportionately
impacts but benefiting um the well-offs
I think it's quite an interesting
approach but then you know maybe she
thinks that actually it's the approach
that will work we had someone like
Johnson who loved to be liked who loved
to change his policies based on what was
popular and maybe she thinks actually
what the public and what MPS want is
someone who's got a firm idea of how to
you know fix some of the issues that are
facing the UK and is going to stick to
them come what may well yes and let's
take a look at the front page of the eye
then Camilla mortgage rate shock as
trust Cuts UK taxes and the prediction
here that interest rates could Rise by
two percentage points in the next four
months because we've got this situation
haven't we at the moment where this
trust says she wants to promote growth
and yet we have very high inflation
yes that's right and I suppose inflation
was of course the big thing that Rishi
sunak kept going on about drawing the
leadership campaign
um in contrast to Liz truss's um Vision
which was all about going for growth and
will inject these stimulus into the
economy and over time that will help
inflation but here on the iPhone page
it's a real Stark reminder that
inflation is a ongoing and very current
problem for people and that affects not
only that energy bills their utility
bills but but also their mortgages and
this is saying it will cost the average
household 200 pounds extra a month on
tracker deals so these kind of rising
inflationary costs are still going on in
the background and even with these um
measures list trusses introducing they
won't immediately be able to solve the
problem with inflation maybe inflation
will come down over time but there is a
real current
um crisis with Rising costs and there
wasn't really anything that's going to
help that in the short term at least so
Justin how much of a gamble is this
policy do you think
I mean I think it's quite a big one I
think you know most
economists and lots of people in the
treasury are agreed that actually the
current status quo with the economy
isn't that great it's not necessarily
benefiting everyone but I do think the
the stakes are quite High obviously
trust has a huge parliamentary majority
but that was off the back of Johnson's
2019 general election when it's not off
the back of you know any overriding
personal support towards trust and I
think what she's got to be really
careful of is as Camila said if people
feel like they're worse off each month
that overall feeling of having less
money in your pocket being that bills
are getting more expensive feeling like
you can't see a doctor this general
feeling that actually life isn't good
then that's actually going to be very
dangerous for trust because people will
be looking back and thinking hang on a
minute we've had years of conservative
leadership is my life getting any better
and I think those questions and that
feeling of unease are going to be very
dangerous for trust so she's going to
really need to sell her policies to the
to the public and at Camilla we're going
to kick off this section with the front
page of the Daily Telegraph and a lot of
focus on Ukraine once again now that
russian-backed areas of Ukraine are
proposing referendum this weekend on
whether the that area should join Russia
what are the implications of that
according to this
yeah so this is quite a significant
development in Ukraine these are um Pro
Moscow leaders and four Ukrainian
regions
um declaring that they're going to hold
these referendums in a series of
coordinated announcements and this makes
up 15 of the country's territory so it
is quite significant and this is seen as
Paving the way for Russia to formally
Annex these sections of of land and of
course this has been roundly condemned
by the International Community saying
that these so-called referendums are a
sham they're going to have no standing
in international law
um but it is quite a significant um
development and in addition to this this
article points out
um that Russia is currently rushing
through some new laws
um aimed at stricter punishment for
disaster and for disobeying orders so
this is being seen as potentially a
precursor to a fuller mobilization of
Russia's troops because at the moment
they haven't got full-scale com
conscription they're only using um a
part of that Army then by no means using
their full Army at the moment in Ukraine
so a few quite major developments here
um potentially showing that Russia is
ready to to try and um really seize on
the land that it does have control of
and and try to really bring that under
its control yeah and I and I said
russian-backed areas I meant
russian-backed leaders in areas in
Ukraine you're absolutely right and this
is something that we will um visit again
at the top of the hour and the 11th but
let's move on for now shall we
adjustment to the metro and they are
leading once again with a focus on the
royal family a return to Balmoral is
their headline there with King Charles
um apparently heading in that direction
yeah so obviously we've had the 10 days
of national morning and we're seeing the
return of parliament tomorrow and things
sort of resume as normal but obviously
for the rural household they are still
grieving and I think it's important to
note that you know throughout the past
few days we've really seen the Royals
put on a very dignified public face and
you know in the midst of what be what
must be a lot of you know personal
turmoil the loss of a mother or
grandmother and so I think it's quite
right and fair that actually
um you know the king and the queen
consort are taking that time away from
the public eye to process what's
happened you know it's a huge transition
to lose a lose a parent and then you
know find that you are you know the king
of the country so I think the yeah it
just touches on the fact that you know
yes we have the King as a sort of public
figure but also he's an individual who
has lost a parent and actually that
takes time to you know you need to take
time to agree with that as well yeah
absolutely especially when you've been
so busy during the course of the week
you need that time and attending to the
Daily Mail error they are talking about
they claim it's an exclusive Camilla and
they say that the king's coronation is
likely to be shorter smaller and less
expensive than his mothers as he vows to
modernize the monarchy
yes exactly so this headline Thoroughly
Modern monarchy is um really pointing to
I suppose King Charles's vision for the
monarchy and focusing specifically on
the coronation saying it's going to be a
slim down a sort of shorter more
streamlined process
um in in recognition of the fact that we
are facing this cost of living crisis
and he doesn't want to feel too out of
sync and out of touch with
um what the rest of the population are
going through that the Articles also
saying the coronation is going to try to
be inclusive and reflective of the
country and the Commonwealth so okay we
must leave it there